it's back to work day or is it today was
supposed to be when people started to
ease very slightly out of lockdown but
for all the commuters on trains and
buses is that really happening here's
one man who wants to know with the
economy having shrunk last quarter at
the fastest rate since the financial
crisis the Chancellor says it's time to
start using the r-word the first quarter
was that bad based on just a few days of
the impact of coronavirus in March so
yes it is now very likely that the UK is
facing a significant recession to it at
the moment and this year the depth of
that recession will depend on how many
people do go back to work or indeed
whether social distancing rules make
that impossible according to those GDP
numbers the wearing apparel sector faced
the biggest of all contractions in q1
and a whopping 19% but this floating
company in Telford is now getting the
machine's rolling again this time
specializing in personal protective
equipment we're definitely seeing an
increase we've got a lot of companies
coming back to us now for PPE so they
can get their workforce back to work but
I think it is a slow trickle and we're
also having supply chain issues
ourselves there's a lot of stock
shortages especially around PPE but some
work as though confusion still reigns
about whether the lockdown rules have
actually changed so there are some
sectors where people can be at work
today particularly in manufacturing or
construction for example where they
can't work from home but that's not a
change in the rules is that they could
they could have worked anyway and many
of them have been but not all of them
and we think it was important to make
sure that those who could work and their
businesses could be open that they felt
secure enough to be open so that is now
completely something that is happening
now the subtext here is that in some
sense of the lockdown has been even more
successful than the Treasury had really
expected more people working from home
more people on the furloughs scheme but
not just from those core sectors it was
focused on initially and that means more
taxpayers money spent on it and
potentially an even deeper recession all
the more reason why the transyl is
determined to press every button he can
and restart the economy getting people
back to work if only it were that simple
for instance much as it would like to
this food manufacturer in Portsmouth
can't really get fully back to work
because its customers mainly the
hospitality sector are definitely out of
action it's frustrating but it's down
heartening because we've got a team of
people here waiting to come back to work
if the hospitality sector perhaps
doesn't open until October or even 2021
I just don't know how we'll manage that
you see there was no simple but new
compressed have restart the economy
because guess what companies are making
their own minds up about whether it's
safe to return so back to that question
at the start did more people take to the
roads and get back to work today
actually the amount of rush hour traffic
in London fell compared with Monday and
Tuesday at Conway's car news